anh alo
ừ ừ
ờ chào bạ
lại mái tóc dễ ạ
ờ ờ
Xin chào bạn
anh Minh tranh thủ à Tâm sự tí trước khi
cậu có các bạn on gì à
Ở đây có một cái hôm trước là thời gian
thì à
hai thí mặn thân mình nhiều lúc chắc
chắn rồi Nhiều lúc mình cũng tâm trạng
không ổn bởi vì à mình nhà ở hướng ngoại
mình sẽ bị ảnh hưởng cảm xúc bởi ỉa
Ừ cái nguồn năng lượng xung quanh kiểu
thế nên là có lúc mình sẽ thể không ổn
Thật và nghĩa mình từng nói về cái cái
cái này rồi thì phải nhớ nói chưa Nó
kiểu cách để mà ông Tâm Sự
khi đèn mấy ông ăn ổi một người khác
Ừ thì à Có thể nói qua cho họ kiểu là họ
cái tầm quan trọng của họ như thế nào
một đầu quan trọng với chính mình hay có
thể quan trọng những người xung quanh
thì nó họ cảm thấy kiểu họ
Mà họ bán được trân trọng họ
quan trọng họ trong quan thì họ sẽ không
bớt suy nghĩ tiêu cực đi họ sẽ thấy vui
hơn cảm thấy họ sẽ muốn sống có ý nghĩa
hơn và Vân là như thế đấy là một cái mẹo
rất là hay
A Gọi mẹ rất hay kia ông muốn cậu an ủi
một ai đó có ai đó đang bị chứng ta thực
ra thì xung quanh không biết các bạn thế
nào nhưng xung quanh mình là mình
Ừ mình ngoài những cái người bạn mà kiểu
ở
Cày cuốc được ngày đêm ra thì cũng có
nhiều bạn thỉnh thoảng thỉnh thoảng hơi
bị tiêu cực một tí theo cầu là ở đáy họ
sẽ nghĩ việc là
khi họ tiêu cực Có có người tiêu cực cực
cực nghĩa là họ thậm chí còn là kiểu bảo
họ đã bị chứng cảm này họ phải cần đi
khám họ nghĩ đến cả việc là kết thúc các
thứ thứ có nhưng mà cái cách giải quyết
của tôi đấy tôi bảo đấy khí thì thì ngồi
tâm sự với họ xong rồi à Nói họ là cậu
họ thừa nhận họ tịch thu
ở cái cua sống của họ đang rất có ý
nghĩa với rất nhiều người chứ không
Không nên ích kỷ đôi khi cái suy nghĩ về
cái khái niệm là tự kết thúc cuộc đời
của mình ấy thì nó nó trong rất nhiều
trường hợp bị vẫn bị cho là ích kỷ nó
còn là không không quan tâm người thân
này không có tâm người
ấy không quan tâm những người đã quan
tâm với mình cái thứ vân vân Ái
Ừ Tự nhiên tôi Tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải
lưu lại điều này vì tôi thấy ạ thực thực
tế nhá thực tế khi mà tôi hồi trước tôi
đọc mì cái về tâm lý học cả các thứ thì
và chính xác và đương nhiên là bây giờ
nói thẳng là bây giờ nhiều giới trẻ bây
giờ hơi bị à nghĩ sai về cái khái niệm
bệnh trầm cảm Hồi trước tôi từng Lựu Lưu
cái bài thử thế thôi cá ở Tôi đã từng
nghỉ hè rồi bị trầm cảm nhưng mà không
anh đi ra mình không thấy nói như thế
nhưng mà có đúng là nhiều người
đề nghị vẫn đang nghĩ mình bị trầm cảm
thật và họ một là họ có làm quá nên có
thể là cậu để mong đợi sự quan tâm Vân
đấy nhưng hay là họ bị thật nhưng mà
những người bị thật có nhiều người còn
không biết họ bị trầm cảm cũng có nên à
Ừ cái hồi mà tôi đọc truyện tâm lý nó
chỉ đơn giản này có ai cũng có bị một
cái bệnh tâm lý nào đó chẳng qua họ bị
mức độ nhẹ ai cũng sẽ bị bệnh tâm lý họ
bị bệnh liên quan đến thần kinh nào đó
nói thẳng ai cũng có thể bị tâm thần
nặng thế nhờ họ đang ở mức cường độ Rất
là nhẹ kiểu thế
ở Berlin làm gì có khái niệm thật ra
khái niệm người một người bình thường
không có mua cái bệnh tật gì nó rất là
vợ nó rất là sai ai cũng có ưu và nhiều
của họ và ai cũng sẽ có nỗi sầu riêng
của họ và nỗi sợ đấy nó sẽ
anh kể cả nỗi sợ hãi sở thích vọng sẽ dễ
hình thành ra một cái thói quen xong rồi
sẽ dễ biến thành một căn bệnh nào đó Giả
sử thế Văn Vân
cho dù ở bệnh tâm lý về sợ đám đông sở
phát biểu
trước tập thể ấy sợ tàn nháy và Vân rất
nhiều này thì nó là một cái đôi khi nó
sẽ kiểu hình dung ra khi mà mình lúc đầu
mình sợ thế xong rồi về sau mình tránh
tiếp xúc nhất ở hệ cơ thứ nó hết hàng em
một cái bệnh tâm lý thôi
thì tôi bảo rồi Thỉnh thoảng thôi sẽ có
có cái suy nghĩ tâm sự với có nghĩa là
chia sẻ được mấy ông mấy ông
cảm thấy à Kiểu mình cũng đồng cảm thì
tốt Có một người Kiểu
khi có một người rồi cũng suy nghĩ thế
chẳng hạn thế
à vì tôi vẫn hưởng đến là không phải là
kiểu chỉ dạy học bằng mấy ông chúng ta
đến đây dạy học giỏi tắt máy đi thế này
như thế là kiểu đôi khi mà
Ừ
cái chính những cái tâm sự khiến lo tiền
cho chúng ta gần gũi nhau hơn cũng như
kiểu ở
áo kiểu Đỡ bớt xa lạ đây gần gũi hơn thì
thì những cái khác những người khác mà
tôi chia sẻ thì mình cũng sẽ đông cảm
hơn
ca nhạc ok thì hôm nay trở ra thì
Xem lại lịch cả tôi bảo là cuối tháng
Nói chung là mình sẽ cố cốt hết kiểu cốt
sao cho mà đến kiểu hết tháng này là gần
như là sẽ sẽ gần ngờ không cần phải cốt
mấy nữa mà chỉ tập trung làm ạ
làm tài liệu nữa là ngồi sửa một Sửa tài
liệu và xưởng cốt nếu có vấn đề mất vì
Tết đi tới lại cận Thuận Cần Thơ tớ đấy
thì
hình ảnh trước và mình thông báo là hôm
nào nghỉ nhưng không Mùng 10 mà không
mùng 10 tháng 9 mà đúng không
anh hả Đúng rồi hình như là mình bảo
mình sẽ linh hoạt để mà kia sẽ kiểm tra
các nhóm mà xem có nhóm chế độ nào có
thể là nói chung một tấm giữ hàng thôi
chỉ mùng 10 17
Ừ thì mình sẽ bảo vệ chính thức
thì nói chung à Bây giờ các buổi buổi
Thứ bảy này thì mình sẽ cho các bạn bảo
vệ tổ Nếu mà nhóm nào có nhu cầu đồng
mạng còn không thì mình sẽ vẫn là review
qua cốt các bạn xem tiến độ Các bạn đang
làm đi đâu các bạn cần là cần bổ sung gì
không Nhưng thực tế thì như mình bảo thì
con tất cả chỉ cần chữa qua chỗ mẫu
trong 1 và nhóm thôi mà có nhờ các bạn
cũng gọi là biết một cách tương đối rồi
mình nghĩ à được kiểm tra những ngày
giống như kiểu kiểm tra bài tập nó hơi
bị nó hơi bị mang tính chất nó hơi bị
được
Anh hơi bị nặng nề mình cảm thấy thế chỗ
được mình không Mình không muốn ngồi coi
Nó là một cái dạng như là cái bài tập
xong mình ngồi kiểm tra kiểu điểm danh
như thế mình thì ra không không thích
bởi vì tất cả mọi thứ đều trên tinh thần
tự nguyện mà đúng không nên là nhóm nào
mà muốn mình chấm thì thì có thể nói
mình và đói nhóm là muốn chữa chi tiết
tính năng gì và vân Thế thì nó mình thì
mình sẽ kiểu chấm cho các bạn đấy thì nó
sẽ ổn hơn thay vì kiểu mình cư ngồi à
áo kiểu mở kodi nay có thể bạn thấy
không thoải mái kiểu đấy
Ừ nếu không hiểu gì không có thể có rất
nhiều bạn sẽ không hề thoải mái
họ biết họ có thế nào rồi ho chiến là họ
không thích không thích người khác mới
Xem cốt của mình và vân tối thì có thể
ngắn nhằm tôi
giả sử br là sử hồi mà tôi đang tốt xấu
tôi cũng chẳng muốn kiểu công khai cho
mọi người xem cốt của mình làm gì cả Bây
giờ thế
- là đương nhiên là để anh em cùng rút
kinh nghiệm với nhau nhưng mà có người
không thích chồng ngoại
à mà có những người rất thích của mình
góp ý trả nợ thế nên là nên là nhóm nào
mà muốn mình góp ý chỉ chi tiết hơn có
những thứ cứ bình luận nhá ạ
ờ ờ
mà bổ sung gần đây thôi Vậy nhé
từ ngày 13 đi à
ông kể
anh nói nhóm 6A
bài hát rành mạch hơn một này
cái thứ
đã bảo tôi giờ mày ông sẽ thế ở gà trông
có vẻ hơi bị vụn vặt một tí nhưng mà đầy
nhỏ nhỏ lên rồi về sau mình sẽ dễ sửa
hơn
tôi đã chấm cá nhòm mà
sửa cốt sửa đến đâu rồi Sửa đoạn nào rồi
Có Vân
à à
Cả ngày hôm nay ngồi học Quốc mới nghỉ à
cả hai lực tối nghĩa hay là hôm nay mình
sẽ thu học Út mới đi anh ta các người
ông có vẻ Đang nha
Em đang chờ tôi Có vài nhóm đang chờ tôi
để chữa cái
số điện thoại phó Tối nay chữa cái à
a bit What is expected Ok
chữa cái folder
Hay là để hôm nay tôi sẽ chữa cho mấy
ông này cái full đâu nhé
ở
cầm chấm cốt kỹ hơn
review code
thì bình luận nhé
số nhóm nhé
Còn không thì mình
cho mình coi ngựa các bạn kiểu vẫn đang
tiến độ làm mình cho mình sẽ kiểu
mình mình sẽ cẩu
chấm hôm sau hôm hôm thứ Bảy thì hôm thứ
bảy bảo vệ này được Bà làm sao dậy tiếp
này hôm thường trở
anh Tuấn Mở cạnh nhà nhà là sao Anh
không phải làm mở làm chủ nhật nghỉ đậu
xanh Ừ có gì tâm sự tuổi hồng ngày 20
à à
thì
đi lâu lắm rồi tôi không động rồi Cái
này là tôi không Nhớ lắm đâu
để tôi thử xem nha à
Ừ cái full scandal này thì
ừ ừ
Em chưa biết rồi các bạn sẽ muốn chữa
theo cậu mức độ như thế nào nhưng mà giờ
để ít nhất ít nhất để tôi sẽ đến cậu
à à
Ừ vợ tôi có cái bảng cái gì nhỉ Có bạn à
ừ ừ
vậy
ngoài
mình có bảo booking này
mình cũng á
Ừ cứ cho là rảnh đi bởi vì bến tầm mà
tháng Tháng sau và tháng sau nữa thì
mình sẽ khá bận ấy đang cân nhắc lại vụ
đấy nó cậu ở mình sẽ không nói chung dạy
nốt trong khóa này thôi sau đó Đương
nhiên là các bạn vẫn thể inbox để mà cậu
hỏi đáp mình thì mình vẫn sẵn là trả lời
thoải mái Nhưng mà
Ừ
nhưng mà cậu nói chung là nó sẽ không
cậu thường xuyên on như này nữa mà về
sau chắc là thích mà mình sẽ thông báo
với đội sẽ like cốt vào kiểu vào
ông chủ nhật Kiều từ thế
nhóm nhóm nào cần chữa thì mình chữa
nhóm 28 à ok ok máy8
ở Sorry có nhiều vàng nhiều thế à
năng này của mấy ông lắm không biết cậu
cách chữa sẽ chữa nha Để xem nào ạ
a
story of api
Ừ đấy ctim Anh check in check out đấy
toàn bộ lên da
ông kể
à à
tủ bếp
season ID
season level
a loạn luân khoảng thời gian này
anh
không viết tắt kiểu này nhá ông ngoài
cậu cốt kiểu đấy xấu
xấu kính không còn ngồi viết tắt ấy vãi
chưởng fvl không hiểu FL là gì à
Vãi chưởng
nhanh
biến thành 1 2 3 rồi nha
cập nhật lại
Anh
check in
à à
ừ ừ
ô nhiễm mặt thời gian lớn hơn
riêng để hiểu được là là
số k là là bao nhiêu
Ừ đấy gọi là ghét ca thằng ạ bé suýt
đánh kiểu thế
à à
Ừ nếu mà không nằm trong mấy cái này thì
ra
à à
đã có trường hợp Nó ship bằng không vậy
pi kết cốt ở
các bài khác
thứ hai mỗi em
thiết kế toán thành Android lời 0
khi bé bên nhau diện bên bác em của ông
đã đấy đầu này có vai đấy rồi còn không
kiểm tra đã đăng nhập hay không
lấy ra điểm danh anh không thì Insert
góc bếp
Ừ cái này thì thay bằng cái câu update
a-class là được rồi
chị sẽ chỉ như hai thôi
nó sẽ bị mắn lỗi đây đúng không thường
mà nó sẽ như này này
có ai
xe tải sẽ có hai câu truy vấn không
anh nghe đây này à
Ừ cái này Jackie nhưng mà không up biết
chứ tao cũng chưa hiểu lắm à
Vì sao này đi
khi hút hay vào đây
I Pray mặc định nó vitamin một nó thành
công đi còn nếu mà update sai thì get ơn
thất bại Ngày đúng chứ Nói Tuấn không
ở sân bay này người ta bây 12 như ngày
tổ không muốn rượt thôi về sau
Nhưng mà chẳng qua các bạn hãy thoát cốt
thì nó như thế này nhưng mà khiến nó
chính cái việc các bạn hóa cốt hot luôn
vào trong đó bay kiểu 123 xong rồi nha
khi mà lấy cốt ra cốt các bạn bị xấu
đúng kiểu nhà luôn đấy 123 123 nha
mình nghĩ là nó sẽ ra gấu một cuộc là
cột level chẳng hạn hay gì đó nó ổn hơn
nhưng thôi bạn ơi trong nó cứ kiểu gì
à
ở trong cốt này xấu quá à
từ trường hợp hay thôi Gì
tạo một cái đấy
Ừ mai Bus Driver song sinh ở đây gastric
này
à à
không
Em nạp thẻ song thực ra không cần
nhìn đây mình sẽ chuyển thẳng ship vậy
tham đây luôn này
A Happy tôn ở đây à
em chỉ mỗi chữ A với Jackie nữa mà ngon
à à
đáng lẽ là mày cái cái này đơn giản hơn
cho mấy ông rất nhiều rồi Nó kiểu nó
thay vì tạo nhân này cột nó sẽ chỉ là là
gì nhỉ
ờ ờ
instead and invest in late check-out
Airblade Lead 2
những chiếc áo start cao and
a nice Staff and start m
à à
là những cái phạt này đúng không
Ừ cái này thì hợp lệ này đúng không
Ý em là cái gì
Ừ tôi chưa hiểu cái chữ i nanon lắm
không rồi ông giải thích cậu tôi
à à
e băng nhá để xử lý và Toán máy bị nóng
máy
phim hài
cậu về bảo vệ không được đi xem lại nha
chồng rồi hả chưa
a second ship này bằng derajat gọi đến
Như Lai
đặt tỉ lệ thích
nó chẳng khác nhau à ê bài làm mọi thứ
đơn giản hơn rất nhiều
à à
ở Ao này
khi hiến pháp được luôn à
ừ ừ
à à
em
chuyển hàng trong ngày Cứu Thế có ham ở
đây
thì thay đổi mỗi chiếc ao đúng không
chế cao thể gặp lại lần 2 hộp lại là một
Nó là chị ạ
ừ ừ
không là để biết được nó đi muộn hay
không mà đúng không
anh ở đây không hề biết được là thằng
này đi muộn 20 này nữa
tra là là ở buổi sáng hay buổi chiều
buổi tối à
A vẫn có ship trong trường hợp ship bằng
không ở nhà
thử gọi Mít đi anh anh phải ngồi nó Dạo
này thử cái khó hiểu rồi thích quá
ở Vịnh đậu làm cos nó bị gặp lại cốt cốt
Cậu trông nó trông cốt được này sợ thật
ông đã kiểm tra bác cái đâu
A monologue kiểm tra nó làm gì
Ừ nó bảo cốt lặp lại con xin nó mà chết
tốt xấu nó cũng trẻ
à nhầm nhầm nhầm
Ừ thôi đàn
anh không con trai mày Cởi trần không bị
sao cả con gái mà có vấn đề
ai
dễ bị ăn phù hợp
hai triệu chín tiền điện xong thế là tôi
phải á phải
anh không dám mở điều hòa
hòa bình thường
[âm nhạc]
à à
Đừng có thương anh
anh alo Ừ OK OK anh nghe thử thôi
em em xem qua YouTube Hay em muốn xem
qua viết luôn à
để ý ra bay của em để cho đoạn này thì
nó ra nhà quá bắt đầu anh cũng nói là về
cái vấn đề là em có làm cho các bài toán
là sẽ được phép muộn kiểu 2 kiểu cho mọi
khía là làm q12 30 phút nữa Ừ anh ấy anh
hiểu cái đấy em à Ý là bây giờ rồi đó em
hỏi người ta đây rồi nhưng mà không
không phải đặt tên cái đặt tên là không
quan trọng Quan trọng là khi mà em tạo
ra thành
2 cột như thế cậu nó thì đồng nghĩa việc
là em bị lặp lại Cốt nó hai phát như này
em định nghĩa làm chuyện là cứ
anh cứ có thêm số cột thì em lặp lại lặp
lại cốt đúng không Mình thực ra mình
A gọi như nào nhỉ
anh em mình tối ưu được thì cậu là mình
tách ra thành một cái có một cái riêng
thì tốt
Ừ nhưng mà thôi Lỡ để nhà rồi trai để
ngồi sửa lại có thừa thử lỡ lằng nhằng
tình trạng xe Tôi yêu được chỗ ở khác
không à
làm xong chưa tối trước chưa tới rồi Ừ
thì đúng đúng là các bạn sẽ không Thời
gian tối ưu mày các bạn này
các
bạn này đang không hiểu lắm Dạo này cốt
xử lý như thế nào nhỉ Cái này anh em sẽ
để mua được Còn cái này
không tay anh thử ở đây nha dep chuyện
đi femen lên là ok đấy tất cả ngon từ
ban đầu là sẽ có thể diễn tả mở đây là
bên kế toán thì tức là tất cả các ngọn
cho tất cả MP này em có cái là
nhiều nó bảo đang ở trong nó thì không
không có việc kế toán của công an thì em
đã xem hôm nay chắc ảnh khoảng ba mà nó
cũng công việc đấy ạ
em lấy toàn bộ tên Phòng Ban
ừ ừ
Có gì em luôn cả nên bảo hiểm sợ trong
trường hợp này em đổi tên của Bonnie Kim
em đâu cho nó kêu chim em bảo là phải
hợp chẳng ai công ty mà đã thiết lập thì
đổi tên mà ngoan nghiệp luôn
anh không Không ai làm thế Cả
việc bây giờ gọi em luôn chuyển công
việc thì em sẽ đúng vị trí rồi đi đổi
thì trong a common nếu cái ấy
Anh không yêu mà nếu thế là nó sẽ lại
không lấy ra được cái 03 nó cả đi Kết
quả của em nữa như nhau thôi
Đây đây đây em Em phải không
anh bởi vì ở phòng ban đổi trong bảng 3p
là đi qua mình rồi mà
thì nó bằng không mà
Em đừng có nhầm nhé Đúng không em đổi em
đổi trong cái bảng thì femen
thì nó còn bằng không mà đúng không Đây
là phải quen nhau ID để gần nhất là thứ
hai là nếu mà em bắt trường hợp đấy thì
nó lại trường học khác trường hợp đấy là
em
anh em phải dạng Nhanh nhỉ
ở cây cái xe mẹ lịch sử mà theo
đổi tên ở trong phòng ban đi qua mình
rồi nên là kiểu kịch Tên đấy nó sẽ là
tên mới nó không còn là tên cũ việc em
qua nha vì nó sẽ không nghĩa gì cả
Bởi vì chỉ được chia làm 3 thì chả bắt
đầu cá làm xong tháng này rồi thì cái
tên rồi sao có liên quan gì hả
Ừ thế thì thôi Các em vẫn chửi Where in
theo ID thôi chứ were phòng ban anh Anh
chưa ở dưới khái niện were mềm IDM
em ở nhà cảnh sát à Nếu mà phòng ban bị
đổi tên thì rõ ràng là nó đã bị đổi rồi
thì em quay cho nó xài nghĩa em phải
Goodbye theo cái hoàng thằng cũ thì nó
mới có ý nghĩa
theo như anh đã hiểu nhé là em chuyển
lên ID của phòng ba đầy đúng không nên
là tên Đừng có viết tắt nữa không phải
ghi rõ ai đi như này đấy
anh nha
a bitumen nếu bị như vậy quá
ở nhà như này đấy
anh em muốn đấy á
A scar để thế đi bỏ qua cái đi mình sẽ
bí đao bình tĩnh đây đây sẽ là em em còn
lưu lại ID phòng ban Không không lưu gì
à Không lưu thế đi mà sao không lưu ai
đi phòng 3A
à Dạ
khi
bị bắt đầu từ cái thằng kia có đủ màn
không đưa cái gì ạ
thôi à
ở hiện tại mà
thì mình sẽ câu chứa vần như này quay di
này à
chú bò tackiness ở dưới này series sẽ là
thằng ở dưới á
ờ
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu mà truyền cái này lên
ô ô thì không sao nè vì nó khá cô đi rồi
nó khác cô thì mình sẽ
ừ ừ
là à
đúng không Thì mình mới lấy tên phòng
ban nha xong mình sẽ que theo tên phòng
ban đấy Con không thì mình mặc định lấy
hết toàn bộ phòng ban thì thôi
hết toàn mặc định toàn bộ lấy hết phòng
ban của tháng trước và năm đến năm vào
tháng một mình chuyển lên đúng không Thì
Thôi
Ừ đúng rồi mày ạ
à à theo theo cái này cái này là kế toán
à
khi mở nó cực kỳ kế toán Còn không thì
sẽ theo Thế còn á ồ theo thì toán ạ
Không phải
thôi kế toán à
Hà Tĩnh nào đấy sẽ là
xem nhé à
ai nó không cho copy rồi Cái thứ
chi tiết
à à
bố mẹ cái này được máy
ờ ờ
Ừ không hẳn là tối ưu nói Trâu ạ cậu
anh Bởi vì a của em đang mặc định lấy
theo cái thằng đầu tiên là sau đó thì em
lại quen lại kiểm tra nữa were phát nữa
thì hai lần câu truy vấn đúng không
Ừ thì bây giờ nó sẽ thành một câu ngàn
đỡ hơn một tí thôi
các clip Xuân
ừ ừ
lấy Ở trong
cài ATP đúng không
ừ ừ
đi
massage ở
can't spend thế
à à
em vẫn Đây là tiền phạt nhớ đúng không
khi mở FIFA
ở đây tất cả phạt đó có những phạm gì
nhỉ À ở đây đi muộn một đi 121 đi xem
lại vậy Mà số 1 số 2 á
ở cái đoạn này nên cách lại phải sau nếu
mà tối ưu thì cách cả được
cô nhóc chẳng thay đổi mấy mày đúng
không
ngủ được
Ừ cái phạt này để thay đổi á Khác
Anh Hướng nhậu ngu như mày thì anh à là
là nó ít thay đổi điều đó
mình cứ cách lại khi là thay đổi thì
mình xóa cách đi
Ừ mình Cập nhật lại cách đó
mấy cái ảnh hưởng có ý có thường xuyên
thay đổi đâu Cái này cái này vừa phòng
nào cũng yêu em cũng xem đến các bạn
video anh gần đây không xem em bây giờ
Xem cách
không Không anh đang gợi ý thì thôi chứ
không phải bây giờ mày làm luôn đâu
mà tại sao em tao Xuống dòng Mày cứ đoạn
này làm gì đấy
Ừ dạo này chú em tôi có lý do lắm
á cái điện con rồi Dạo này
ở đây em không có cái đoạn đấy Em chỉ
biết thêm này ở
ăn trộm sợ quá
Cái này cái này đặt tên nó dễ hiểu hơn
em ạ Mình sẽ tạo một cái họ lại một cái
A build a một cái
Ừ ừ một cái IQ nữa cũng được sau đó thì
mình Japan toàn bộ về đây là trong cái
đấy không thích không biết anh chưa thử
vụ đấy bây giờ thử
bộ phim
một ngày ta thấy file nào tét rồi nhỉ
Em đừng có
ở đây đấy á Không không ý anh ạ
mà hãng sẽ thử test vào nhóm của bạn AK
à à 3521
Thằng bé đi à
à à
i
tớ không Sao không ra anh em đang muốn
test thử mà
cost of fun
đường này
đội hẳn cho nó sang bàn khác đi à
em có bán ở đây bạn ơi
cái này tạm khỏe chưa Bill nó nhìn cho
đâu từng minh hơn thay vì Kiểu nhìn đoạn
này trong rối quá à
à mà sẽ là
ô nghe gọi nó là ghét thấp yêu nhỉ Đúng
rồi Tết
thế này sau đó thì mình sẽ có
I Just Can't
khi cài đặt Tết modi Lazada
cho phép Một Sẽ Trở Về
a a b c Ngạn
Em hãy soi thằng này sẽ tốt này sau đó
thì
à à
The Men
I know that thôi
Ừ chắc thế chạy thử nhé
búp bê
thích sân à
à à
web mặc định phải
ở đây chưa hả em mới được về
Tik
Tok remix
à à
xin lỗi
đã test họ đến Tân 1
ở hà thằng này nó không được nghỉ
à à
thôi mình sẽ gọi điện thoại hàng ngày
append
khi được mày nghỉ à
à à
à hay là một thử cái việc à Thằng này có
gọi được thằng nó Penh con khác không
có vẻ không được à
anh
có nhìn cái viết cái đoạn code pet này
nó dài quá
rồi
a set of Clans
em heo thức kem massage
Bởi vì nếu mà có thể mà gọi theo kiểu
truyền Lotte được thì mình sẽ có thể có
thể mình sẽ kiểu khai bám cái giả sử ở
đây như này cái kiểu Tara
nó nó được mày
Ừ ừ tất cả có thể Vứt cái này và một cái
hàng
tham dự án xử lá xét hả em
ờ ờ ờ
ô tô Boost toàn bộ kĩ năng này
dự báo trong ngày
em không trả về cái gì cả
cô gái thì bên này nó sẽ rất là ngắn gọn
nó sẽ chỉ nhắn gọi thằng này
này Phước thì mình có thể làm được cái
trò này
the first Còn nếu mà nó giúp kẻ ghét
giống như bạn này trên làm thì cái này
không Nó giúp được trừ khi mình à mình
lại phải chạy vòng lọc để mà thêm vào
ca nhạc karaoke là bản chất là nó chạy
vòng ngọc về thêm vào đấy
trường sửa đây những cái chỗ mà kiểu sẽ
tên gì theo này nó sẽ có thể thêm vào
được đấy
ngày có thể trả lời giúp
à à
Anh
Ừ ok
thêm vào này
khi
trở về
anh về sau mình sẽ có thể sửa
Ừ mình hay sửa cái trong này
events cái gì đó nữa nó xóa bớt đi cũng
được
mà nên ngắn gọn thôi toàn bộ cái wed này
thì ra các bạn thì tổng của chỗ khác nữa
cũng được vân sao cho Cốt controller nó
không nên xử lý modal quá nhiều
đang làm rồi à
chị Thu
anh cũng cốt hợp đoạn tỉnh ở Ừ nói cho
ấy vẫn chạy có sao vẫn giữ nguyên đi về
ngồi
ở phía sau anh sẽ thử
cái con con con Phai là khác muốn vui
qua
hả Ừ
bên
đây
chứ lên lần em sẽ lấy dữ liệu à
I love you Cái video của Android à
thì anh mới hiểu tôi chia sẻ màn hình
anh đoạn này anh xem
bộ trang điểm
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
bây giờ rồi nhưng mà
Khi
nào thêm
Ừ
thì em lấy dữ liệu từ bên doc mây rồi
thêm sức Em làm sao thế kiện bởi vì nó
là xem một ngày thì em Thể loại đi nữa
tôi
nghỉ một buổi đến Ngọc bồi dưỡng nào
chùa Thế thì bỏ màu đi em ạ
a cho Vì có những ông gửi em đi làm buổi
sáng nhưng mà em tin xong treo
không treo muộn không phải treo ngọn như
là
không phải về sớm ạ một rồi mà em bỏ
luôn à em quên có thể quên hỏi thì em
dùng một lần
mà vì đây là không màu trắng đây thì nó
sẽ kiểu
gì mỗi sáng nay mới đúng chứ ông nhìn
mắt quá vẫn bảy sắc cầu vồng này sẽ màu
thì sẽ thật sự thật không Không ý anh à
không cần ấy hiển thị này nghỉ đâu
a a word là ngày nghỉ mà đúng không
I
work em dùng ở đây có thể làm gì đó
ví dụ như ở trường hợp của cả ngày nay
Ừ
thêm rồi con màu đấy không nghe nhà bà
bầu nó đi
em có ảnh có cùng nhóm chú bình luận kìa
thật nguội thì anh là con này màu ngày
ngày vui
anh không nên có Quốc kệ đi
người dùng nhìn và lại hiểu là hôm đấy
không điểm ra anh Thế thôi là thế thôi
Ừ ông ông nghĩ nhiều làm gì không nghĩ
bài toán phức tạp thêm gửi ông cần đủ
màu à không cần không cần phải lấp đầy
cả cái bàn này đâu Nó cả on ha mới bị
bằng nó ra là sẽ xin lỗi hả Cái gì lỗi
cho nó hiển thị lỗi ạ Cái này là siêu
nhện chơi nha à
Ở đó có gì sẽ nhảy trên
Anh hiểu ý em về cái vụ để lên trên vì
nó là theo thứ tự nhiên nó không có
Ừ hỏi ừ
Ừ
anh hiểu à
để mua thôi Chứ nhìn trong đau mắt quá
đúng không cái gì nhanh để không biết ở
lầu nhà hợp lý và vì nó sẽ bị mất chữ ạ
bởi vì muốn nó không phân biệt thì không
Làm thế nào để khác biệt giữa hai nhân
viên trong cuộc này vui lòng màu nhiều
hoa sau nha em dùng bằng một chữ nhưng
lại chẳng thì cái màu sắc ảnh hưởng đến
việc không chỉ được chữa
anh không Ý anh là cái màu đỏ
hay cài đặt cạn và không lỡ màu đỏ mà
cái giống như em vừa bảo nên nếu có sẽ
bị đẩy lên trên từ ra đấy là trải nghiệm
không tốt đúng không có bị sai nó bị
lệch không nhỏ mà đặc biệt là càng ghi
rằng là không hiểu ngay đúng rồi
Ừ thôi kệ Vậy anh phải chấp nhận vậy
ờ ờ ờ
xem ngày gì đâu
cả ngày thì này
mỗi ba cái hả em
khi mở Canon L theo ngày nó theo dõi cả
đúng rồi theo giờ chú truyền bờ và mà
Ừ thế kia là giờ mà ông nhưng mà dọn đấy
là sai rồi
đấy Chính vì chú để thay hổ nên thành ra
chúng bị sai đấy Nếu chú để đau giờ thì
nó sẽ cắm chỉnh cho chuẩn
sắp xếp theo kiểu cả một ngày nó sẽ ra
dòng Nó mà em là theo những chiếc theo
như pi mà sao giờ không muốn đi viện thì
được Nó không biết
cái gì cơ Nếu là của một tiếng Việt thì
nó sẽ là giờ sẽ hợp lí nhưng mà nhưng có
nhiều nhân viên nó sẽ bị xét kiểm lần
lượt xếp kiểu chúng ta sáng trưa chiều
xong mà lại lặp lại cái phần cây nhân
viên
này chú đã theo cậu thứ tự kiểu ngày
mình thành ra thế thôi chứ nếu mà em mới
chuẩn của của nó thì đó sẽ là nó sẽ là
của chủ với nhiều nhân viên mà đúng
không Thì thì bản chất là
cái cái này hiển thị đó không quan tâm
thì những thằng đi đúng giờ đâu Nó có
tâm những thằng muộn thôi những cái
thằng muộn thì chị lên kèm theo màu của
những thằng đấy mà không rõ là của thằng
nào người ta nào cho ca nghĩ được nếu
anh muốn kiểu như anh nói kia thì nó chả
tên đầu tiên thì cái nhà thằng này nó
một hai lần hay mỗi một lần mà xin lỗi
em
ưu
tiên sinh nhật bạn
không cũng chưa nghĩ bài toàn á hình
dung được cái bài toán này lắm xem nhé
Nếu mà xem theo ngày đi đúng không Nếu
mà xem cho ngày thì ví dụ Giả sử là buổi
sáng có ba ông đi muộn thôi chẳng hạn
thì anh chỉ cần hiển thị mỗi ba ông đấy
chồng ạ dầu của Tùng ông kèm theo gạch
ngang với tên của ông đấy Chán thế thôi
có giá trị sáng đi
3000 hỏi sáng mà theo ngày và buổi sáng
nay có bao đi muộn thì khung giờ của ông
đấy hiển thị lên thì nó sẽ là ví dụ là
cả ba ông để đi muộn nữ tiêm cùng 8:00
đi giả sử cung chung giờ đi còn mỗi 3
ông thì lên cho màu sẽ như thế nào
anh ạ
Ở
trên
đây đây đây anh thử xem nha Thì nó có
phải anh chị ra em ăn nhìn thấy màn hình
bên nơi này của anh vào ngon thì có phải
hàng tháng 8 giờ thì nó sẽ ở trên này
đúng chứ nhà
ca nhạc đấy bà Tám giờ thì có thể là à
thì nó sẽ có á không như không giờ kết
thúc nhỉ
Ở đây có mua chúng ta không không quan
tâm giờ kết thúc đúng không
nó sẽ hiểu Dạng như này không kết thúc
chính là cái giờ
em dùng bởi vì nó theo ca thì phải có
hai cái là một ta xem khi
các vì sao một cái
cần xem nó chị in vào lỗ như nào mà quan
tâm gì chứ tao chứ tao thì lúc đấy lại
một cái thổ khác sau anh đang nói là cái
tủ cái này chị ghi này đúng không nó
muộn tám giờ đúng không sau đó thì thì
nó có thể hiểu
vì nó có thể là kiểu kiểu dạng là khi
Liệt kê tên của tất cả các ông muộn lúc
8 giờ đây cũng được cũng được hoặc là có
thể là một ông khác cùng chèn vào cùng
lúc mà thấy kiểu hả
em Có nghĩa là những cái quần con nhìn
trong ngày trước nó cả trong này là nhìn
kiểu cái tên Phòng Ban
vị trí nhân viên thì chị ra kiểu cho bạn
được nhưng mà thật ra em đang không gọi
là tận dụng cái phần cả đời nhưng chưa
triệt để rồi bởi vì nó không theo nó
không theo giờ mà nó lại kiểu theo mỗi
ngày hoặc giờ của em bắt đầu đi để chị
cái tháng ừ đúng rồi đấy thì thì nó
không nó không có không theo cái khung
giờ em có chưa Không giờ và đau đúng
không
phải đi được
biết tối gọi là cũng biết tinh chỉnh này
sao cho chị lên là được rồi
Ừ Ok Em em thắc mắc gì nhỉ cái tối ưu
cái à Không
áo đen hỏi
mình nhìn đau mắt à
vụ tai nạn và thay
rồi rồi Ừ cái này có 500 lòng mà có
những điều gì
Cái này
Khi
nào có
tư này
nhạc những dòng này ạ
Ừ anh mở khóa xe rồi Sorry I
ở siêu dòng tựa
đây 1800 lòng đi
với
ông làm này bắt tôi ngồi review cốc này
chết à à
em có chồng vãi chưởng
Em
em về đặc biệt ở bên này Đây là
ở bên nhà Tuyển dụng Mà bảo gửi code cho
ông đừng gửi nhá Không nó đuổi ông ấy
Cốt phần mềm học viện của anh thì đúng
cũng 2000 bay dòng chuyện bình thường
đấy do anh kiểu về sau cũng bắt đầu thù
di ra Suite về một cái file HTML mình
giờ trẻ lại một đống tuyết trong rất là
vấn đề rồi đấy lần nhìn cốt của ông trả
thì cốt tôi Thời đấy
anh
em biết
nhiều
[âm nhạc]
cũng khoe cái gì
tôi thấy ông dành mãi trường cho khi
nhìn thấy dạo này ông ông đặt tên biến
nó còn rảnh hơn ạ
Vì vậy chưa
thì trông nó chẳng nói gì cả
vợ yêu nhớ nô ngùi có
sửa lỗi hỏng luôn đấy ngồi đếm Tôi yêu
chưa ông hợp làm coder đấy
cô đơn cũng ngồi gõ thay vì ngồi vợ gọi
văn bản Mùi có cốt
áo kiểu này ông Kiên gì được cộng chị
ông Tại sao phải ngồi gõ dài nhà Bây giờ
anh thêm anh thêm một vài trường hợp đỡ
thì thêm thêm vào rồi à anh như nào
không
thì anh thêm những cái ô vào đây á Anh
chưa hiểu lắm nhưng nó thì nó sẽ tìm
được giới thiệu ạ
Ừ cái gì thế mà dưỡng cái cây đó Dạo này
cái gì Cái cái đoạn này cái gì Cái này
số mà Đúng không
điểm danh kiểm lại cái số bọn anh bảo là
thêm ở bên dưới bên trái ý
Ồ vãi sửa ông ngồi
góc bên trái
em
có bên chả bộ điện đến số 7 đi muộn đi
Đúng rồi đi chơi à
à À thế à Xong rồi ông ấy ông thay vì
ông tạm một cái Đếm sao ông đập cái
class cho nó không tạo cho từng cái
class1 luôn Xong rồi ông ngồi đếm rồi mà
anh em bởi vì nó là theo tính cả sao
phải thời gian của cái
[âm nhạc]
đúng rồi thì ý anh à với mỗi hàng này
nha mỗi ngày sẽ có một cái đi đúng không
xong em chỉ việc à những cái trả về nó
sẽ kèm theo một cái của nó xong rồi em
chỉ cần đến tổng mấy cái ID đấy là được
em chạy một vòng lặp để đến theo từng
ngày đi một hàng xong rồi em in ra đây
được chứ không phải là em ngồi em đếm
từng thằng một như thế này vãi sướng
không
2007 cốt ông không thấy cốt ông lập lại
ở thầy cô không làm vậy chỉ thấy một tên
biến không
anh đúng không cái đi Thế gì thế thì Đấy
mới gọi là làm kiểu thủ công đó em làm ở
nông dân đây đúng không
à Hôm Sao Đỏ mộ đó này thì các bạn vẫn
được phép nông dân Nhưng mà anh bảo ơi
đừng có khoe cái này cho ai nha
Khoe tao từng cốt 2000 dòng em về cái
gồm
đặt tên biến mất sử 500 đồng rồi à
anh gọi không ai có muốn nhìn lợn con
này đâu cậu về anh review cho anh tối ưu
cho em mình chắc à Chào triển và tăng
xông kết hợp việc là nó không chạy được
thì ngồi chết
Ừ nhưng mà ở đấy thì anh Hưởng các giải
pháp như thế nhá đó là khi em trả về thì
em phải trả về nó em đã trả về nó bao
gồm cả màu rồi Em đã biết được cả nó nó
nó đã là kiểu thuộc thể loại nào rồi
xong rồi Cái cái ở bên khi mà trả lời
hết Xong thì em bắt đầu chạy cái Hà là
đến nó theo từng cái từng cái ID từng
cái kết quả đấy là nó sẽ ra được cái
bảng bên trái thôi
Em mua thêm cái cập nhật bởi vì nó
không 3320
sự khốn nạn chưa quan tâm đến màu thôi
mà quan tâm gì mày kia đâu màu gì màu gì
Nó chỉ I
về
bản chất khi mà chú trả về thực ra chúng
phải biết được là nó đã muộn hay không
rồi chứ Ý
em hỏi là có nên lưu sao phải ra là muộn
hay không anh bảo là liệu nó không phải
không Không không lưu mà đang nói là là
khi mà bác em trở về còn yêu không biết
được là đã muộn anh không rồi mà
sao đây lại cá kiểng
a a ý em à Em muốn trả về file thì em
mới có được kiểm tra đúng không
Anh bảo là
[âm nhạc]
lâu rồi
anh đấy đấy do anh bận vẫn Hà Tĩnh liên
quan đến thể liên quan đến cài đặt tên
cài đặt tên cột đấy nếu mà đặt tên cột
nó dễ hơn thì thì em đỡ phải chạy vòng
lập tạo nhiều biến ngay
à à
ạ Bây giờ ông nào của ngồi đọc cốt của
ông
không hiểu được đâu nhiều đợt này đã gì
không dám động rồi Cho đoạn này
à à
lễ hội ok Nói chung nhà đi giai đoạn này
chạy được giữ nguyên em ạ Kệ con cái gì
nữa
ở
ừ ừ
ở hệ thống kê rồi chưa thống kê được là
à à
có nhân viên nào nhỉ nhiều các mẫu thử
Ừ cái đấy
lương tính lương xong rồi sạc thưởng như
thế nào
cũng đi như đây đây đây em Em đang nhìn
anh đã nhìn thấy kia phạt thưởng thuộc
phe ở bên bên kia đây đúng không
đang
test cùng các thứ xong hết rồi thích thì
làm thêm cái cẩu cái mức lương của từng
người Ấn xem có không Không ý anh là
biểu đồ và mức lương từ người nó
của từng người nhá Không không phải so
sánh người này người kia bởi vì có người
ví dụ Giả sử có người lương 30 triệu thì
họ luôn ở trên cao so với người lương
thấp rồi gì chị sẽ biểu đồ của họ xem ra
xem họ chỗ và chính họ cũng thể xem được
bản thân họ nữa để xem mà kiểu sau Ví dụ
Chọn theo chọn cho năm đi trở lại thế
thì kiểu xong trong máy bay trong năm
nay nhìn nó tăng giảm như thế nào nếu mà
ngoài cái việc tăng giảm của cải lương
thì sẽ bao gồm cả tiền phạt của họ cũng
sẽ tăng Dạ theo thời gian như thế nào
thì không dụ là được cái dụ điển hình
giống như anh vừa là một điển hình anh
tháng trước thì anh bị phạt tận hả
U19 buổi không có học cho não thì sẽ ra
gần triệu hãy cả thế rồi Tháng này thì
mới có hai buổi họ sẽ bị giảm đi cái
tiền phạt cái gì đó hiển thị biểu đồ lên
đều đồ cả lương rồi biểu đồ cả pháp mà
hiểu
à à
Ở
tại một là biểu đồ cái thế xong ơi nói
sung à biểu đồ biểu đồ kiểu à
Anh hiểu rồi Sao em nhìn rồi mà đúng
không anh ấy biểu đồ đúng không ạ Anh
thì làm làm kiểu đấy Sao vẫn rửa nếu đấy
là một cái gợi ý thêm
cho anh Anh chỉ được à anh vẫn không
chuyên ở cái phần mềm kế toán lắm Chẳng
thấy vợ mình thêm các bạn cái gì
Ê mấy ông phải đi Thảo sát vào thì tao
nếu mày đi khảo sát rồi nhưng tôi không
Tôi vẫn tin là thực ra phần mềm Ông vẫn
đủ ngon hơn một phần mềm hiện tại đang
có rồi nhưng mà có thể bài toán nghiệp
vụ có khi lại chưa đủ rằng cái phần mềm
anh có ngon ở đây là ngon thêm kiểu nhất
là giao diện này ngọn thứ hai ở cậu
thống kê các thứ thứ nhưng mà còn bài
toán nghĩa vụ mình mà thiếu thì lại
không ổn không
chỉ làm đến mức nhiều chứ hỏi thì em
đang dùng theo kiểu này tính dồn vào thì
để sau ngày đủ 26 ngày thì phải
tăng ca à
yêu đang ngồi thường và lên song ca của
ca thứ ba sẽ là lên 1,5 Nhận xin rồi vào
cho Lương ngày đầu tiên lưng rất cơ bản
nếu khi mặc đủ hết cái đấy chứ ở đâu Cái
này Quý Đôn ở đâu
lê hiếu động sản trong cốc à à
chứ Quý f7
lượng lưu bản nhạc
không lưu thì uống làm nên cả đơn giản
thôi ông chỉ cần lấy ra được là là tháng
này có bao nhiêu chủ nhật cho ngồi
- số ngày trong tháng với số chủ nhật
thì sẽ ra số ngày số ngày làm vừa bình
ít đấy netbeans ít đây
ở nhà thần carbon có cái Hà Nội phải ạ
các video cái à
chế độ kiểu công ty để lựa chọn xem được
là kiểu 26 ngày không tính tính lương
cao 6 ngày đi làm hay làm theo kiểu theo
từng tháng sẽ số lượng nhí 26 27 hai từ
23 đấy Cái đấy là k thì mình chọn bên sử
dụng vòng chứ không
anh đến thì dùng được trong dùng cái
check à
Anh
Ừ Ok thôi Thế cũng được ở trong mà thôi
cái là em mình về các bạn mày lập trình
viên mình cũng chỉ cần à
Bộ trưởng dạng là bài toán lúc đầu mình
xác định được bà ta lúc đầu là gì sao
mình đưa kết quả giải pháp là gì là ổn
rồi họ để áp dụng được thực tế hay là nó
chính xác hẳn như nào thì
đúng rồi giống như bạn chưa bảo còn
thiếu nhiều cũng như là có thể Nó còn
chưa đúng vào cụ thể của công ty nào đó
bởi mỗi công ty nó sẽ có một kiểu cá
nhau nữa đúng không Đây là mình cũng
không cần phải khắc hai cái vụ này lắm
Ok Nhưng nói chung là anh thấy cũng ổn
thôi
cho con con giống nhỉ ra tại buổi trưa
nghỉ hết
cho cụ thay đổi mới kia tên lại theo
thời gian ok
Em đừng có khoe code nữa nhé sợ qua cái
đấy không khoe được đâu
Xin chào nhé à
ừ ừ
nhỉ ở ga thì à cốt dài chắc chắn các bạn
với tro cốt kiểu gì mà cái dự án đặc
biệt đoán hay kiểu gì sẽ khác đồ ăn bột
kiểu gì Các bạn thấy khác rồi ăn bột
nhiều màu không lỡ rằng có thể cửa xóa
rất nhanh nhưng bù lại bài toán nó khó
hơn các bạn cốc nhiều hơn xong rồi các
bạn lạm dụng à ra Swift các thứ thứ nữa
to lên cái kiểu thế
xe tải phim lý do mà bây giờ nó có
Facebook gia Speed chứ chẳng ai dùng
Yuri để mà làm hội lớn như về rồi đúng
không ạ à đương nhiên là phim Quốc gia
vẫn xinh to nhé Vì sao các bạn vẫn phải
học cách chia nhỏ chưa nhỏ hơn các thứ
thứ thành các con phần nâng nó cá Thử ấy
đôi khi hôm trước tôi đọc một cái đó là
nhà mình có nên lưu lại hết vào trong
một file hay mình cách nhỏ ra file khi
mà tách nhỏ ra pha nhiều quá nó lại tẻ
thì lại thành ra rất nhiều file
Ừ thì hồi đấy sẽ đọc rồi nó nó bạn ạ
trong dự án lớn thì kiểu gì nó sẽ không
to nó không thể ít cốt được cùng nó nó
tách hẳn nữa cô check hẳn ra mua chất
khác nếu mà nghiệp vụ nó bắt đầu có gì
đó thay đổi thì ông tách hẳn hàng Phố
chất khác thì càng tốt để dùng thực càng
tốt tại sao Bởi vì bởi vì nói Thảo ra nó
giống như là nó giống như là bây giờ tôi
đang dùng p 7 mày ông đang thấy không ạ
và Nel 8 đúng trước ấy thì tức là sao
những cái dự án đang chạy đôi khi nó sẽ
dùng những để công nghệ lỗi thời và bây
giờ khi mấy ông muốn phát triển từ tính
năng mới mà tính năng đấy tách ra được
thì nên tách ra thành một cái bôi trách
mới kèm theo những công nghệ mới dụ t89
gì đó không nhầm nhầm level 9 show t800
đấy Ừ nếu mà tách ra được thì là tốt và
mình sẽ gọi thông qua api bản chất là
cũng qua api thôi mà đúng không gọi qua
nó để mà lấy dữ liệu về hay các cư xử lý
sau nếu mà cách ra được thì rất ổn như
thế
và đương nhiên các bạn thấy à các bạn
nghe thế sẽ bảo à nhưng mà những thế thì
em lại muốn viết lại mua đồ rồi các thứ
thứ Nhớ đấy nó có những cái khái niệm mà
là vì tình cảm với cao đưa những cái nó
phải Nếu mà dùng chung người mua đồ dùng
chung cái gì đó thì đúng là vẫn phải
đúng rồi đúng rồi cái khái niệm
Microsoft service xi nhan như thế Nói
chung là dự án lớn thì kiểu gì nó sẽ cho
ra giống như người ta thấy bảo vệ cốt
của Google là 50 tỷ đồng cô là hai 20
triệu nữa
là ai cốt Google gì cả
ca nhạc Google ơi Microsoft đi đây
Google 2 tỷ 2 tỷ trọng giảm cốt có sướng
nhưng có khi khá nhiều Cốt trên á
ô tô Crow copy ở trong ngày à
có ai code mai có shop 50 in triệu đúng
không
ở Trung Quốc phình to ra bình thường
ờ ờ
gì đấy thằng gà cũng là nhược điểm của
Lara đấy Đó là là mình mình gộp chung
hết vào trong controller nó không ổn
Mình tách ra file nó bị nhiều quá bị
thừa quá nhiều quá Cái các thứ và rất
các bạn đang vẫn chưa cho khi các bạn
Quốc TP thì các bạn lại vẫn chưa thực sự
là cố theo kiểu UPU lắm đấy các bạn viết
lặp lại cốt nhiều đấy Cá thứ giống như
ngay về rồi đấy không Không vứt nó vào
trong mua đồ mà các bạn lặp lại Cốc
nhiều đấy nhược điểm của các bạn của của
Chính tôi cũng chỉ bị Đó là kiểu mình có
TP là mình cứ cốt nhưng tộc kiểu thế
thay vì cả tối ưu các thứ khi tinh chỉnh
nó gọn tổng ở chỗ khác hướng đối tượng
đấy do rất nhiều người cậu code Java thì
nó Cốt nó sẽ ngắn hơn hay cái gì đó và
nó có thể tối ưu hơn Thanh Vân
cho mỗi hành thử gọi ưu nhược điểm riêng
nhưng mà về cơ bản thì giao mình thấy
nhá ato Nó vẫn phù hợp cho dự án nhỏ và
vừa có dự án lớn thì đúng là Tết p nó sẽ
có rất nhiều nhược điểm với các dự án
lớn nên là nên là cậu mình cũng bắt đầu
phải học truyền dân ngôn ngữ và và cậu
công ty không thể ốp được vào và sự lớn
ngay hiện tại công ty tôi đã áp dụng là
level dự án lớn thì nó cũng làm phát
sinh nhiều vấn đề nó nó bị chậm với các
thử ngoài tối ưu được thì mình cũng bắt
đầu phải cân nhắc trong việc làm cũng
phải chuyển dần mà Vân rồi
Ừ nhưng mà không sao nào cho nó vẫn cộng
đồng vẫn rất đông không phải là mình sợ
là công nghệ mình dùng nó sẽ bị vấn đề
gì đó không không phải lo gần đây đấy
các bạn vẫn và chuyên sâu một cái
Facebook đã rồi về sau các bạn thích
thích ca muốn tối ưu một cái gì đó Thì
đấy là chuyện của phía sau bây giờ mình
phải học chắc từ một cái đã đúng
Ừ ok à
ông là không nên nhảy vào cút web hay
mang tên Tô gì cả hỗ trợ giùm la hay là
courtney tơ này
già đi
anh chi P J là hai giờ thì đó với tôi
thì
so với bếp về tôi TP chỉ có lao thôi còn
không giống nhảy Hàn sang ngôn ngữ khác
mà họ mà làm mấy cái cái cái Facebook
word platform khác thì thôi rẻ đẹp
ở đây với tôi nha ông thì
Ê mấy ông lý theo ca mỗi cái đều có yêu
ở nhược điểm G mà
ở nhà mặt hình sự thì ông cốt web hay là
Santo xong ấy
em không nhảy dành nguồn khác được thật
ông kho em có bao nhiêu năm kinh nghiệm
tôi không quan tâm người từng thấy rất
nhiều rồi hơi sợ tôi cũng đã làm qua rồi
chứ hoa chưa làm xong rồi đúng cho tôi
tôi dừng thấy rất nhiều được mấy ông học
cái đấy Sao không nhảy được phụ nữ sản
không có kinh nghiệm để làm mức người
khác và cốt rất xấu tôi cao thủ thứ
cho nên được ngõ đừng có tự nhiên anh
học lao tự nhiên đâm đầu vào cái đấy ông
lúc này ông đi lùi đấy này
từ hôm sau tôi để mô cái folder Thứ ba
làm sao nhé Bây giờ mình nghỉ xong rồi
thứ Bảy thì
Ừ thứ bảy mình sẽ Cậu thử bảo vệ thu có
nhóm nào cần bảo vệ thử mình sẽ bảo vệ
không ạ
object cả nó để xe mà thực tế nhá là bây
giờ làm passport check thì vẫn là nên để
cải thiện cái trình độ của các bạn để
các bạn đi làm được đúng không Thì cái
cải thiện cần nhất là các bạn một là ok
rồi vì app.pp như tôi đã nói nó cũng
thành thạo Ok lắm cái hay là có tí đến
qua đến tính toán không phải toán mà
nhưng mà đúng nó là thực toàn nghĩa sao
nó xử lý những dữ liệu lớn những vòng
lọc các thứ thứ chợ hoa cài bài toán
nghiệp vụ thì đừng có để tính dịch vụ
thì tôi không cho nó pass Tôi check nó
sẽ có chắc hẳn lớn rồi đấy
best forex cả cái gì đó thư giãn một tí
thôi thì cái gì có tí đậm toán một tí là
được à
bí mật thứ ba
Các bạn phải
khi các bạn đi làm Bây giờ đi phỏng vấn
các bạn ít nhất là các bạn thể hiện api
là cái gì đấy Thật ra tôi tôi xem lại
cái video cũ của tôi thì đúng là dậy thì
hai các bạn hơi bị loạn thật nhưng mà
bây giờ nếu mà đến thời điểm hiện tại
thì các bạn bắt đầu hình dung được cái
kia nó gì rồi chỉ đơn giản là một là gọi
lên là lấy dữ liệu về hai là đẩy dữ liệu
lên cổ nó là một cách mpall để mình có
thể đẩy dữ liệu lên hoặc lấy giữa về tùy
hãy đơn giản nếu mà chỉ ngắn gọn mấy cái
ai cũng như thế các bạn làm quen với đủ
kiểu ATI các giữ thứ từ việc
đấy thì thường là có những cái trang cẩu
Hồi trước tôi tìm hiểu api Facebook này
xong rồi tìm hiểu tiay Instagram hay cái
gì đấy đồ kiểu ý api cho các bạn mò về
các bạn làm cái trang web theo ý các bạn
trong các chia sẻ ảnh Ai là trang web tự
gì đó chia sẻ nhạc nhiều như tôi ra đi
làm
tự động Quỳ anh gái thì đấy là một cái
kia ai của bên saphir để mình sẽ gọi
điện em gửi ảnh lên cái kia đấy con Vân
đấy để các bạn hình dung hơn được rõ rồi
khái niệm api và reason để làm việc với
thao tác với dữ liệu này
khi nghe những cái gợi ý do các bạn nhé
hôm nay chúng mình tạm nghỉ nhé
còn hót rồi
khi hack có gì Ông tìm hiểu cái tâm bồ
của tôi bạn chết à Có api Cái này nó là
quạ cái cặp bồ nó miễn phí ATI mà ông
gọi đến cái tâm mồ của tôi lại mà lấy
key này
À thế à Hai xinh cài is bằng cái xinh
chọn lọc này mà lấy cái ai nó sẽ trả về
toàn bộ ảnh này
một cái ở mấy ông ngồi mò đã làm cho
boss chưa nhé